darf es einer ministerin egal sein was
ihre wähler denken es ist ein satz von
annalena baerbock der jetzt diese frage
aufwirft und eine große diskussion
auslöst es geht um diesen auftritt hier
von annalena baerbock in prag da sitzt
die außenministerin auf der bühne und
spricht über ihre und über die deutsche
solidarität mit der ukraine und dann
sagt sie eben diese setzte ihr
versprechen an die ukraine das halte sie
egal was ihre deutschen wähler denken
dürfte thomas tippl in uk east end with
as long as juni das denn einwand
roger waters
domatter das gucken wir uns nochmal als
zitat übersetzt an weil diese aussage
jetzt für so viel wirbel sorgt wenn ich
den menschen in der ukraine mein
versprechen geben solange beizustehen so
lange sie uns brauchen dann will ich das
auch halten egal was meine deutschen
wähler denken es gibt viel kritik vor
allen dingen von der afg von der linken
aber auch aus der cdu von außen experte
norbert röttgen kommt scharfe kritik er
schreibt bei twitter das liebe frau
weerberg das ist unnötiger schein
heroismus die mehrheit der deutschen die
sei dazu bereit die ukraine weiter zu
unterstützen und so weiter und dann
schreibt röttgen
es gehe darum in der politik die anderen
mit guten argumenten zu überzeugen und
nicht mit solch einem basta darf eine
ministerin das sagen dass ihr in diesem
fall zumindest der wählerwille egal sei
darüber sprechen wir mit dem focus
kolumnisten und autoren jan fleischhauer
schon guten morgen herr fleischer worden
riesenaufregung wirbel um diese berbalk
aussage ihr seien die wähler egal und
das als ministerin ist das jetzt ein
skandal ist dass sogar wie das bei
twitter insinuiert wird hochverrat
es ist eben ich noch dass die politik
sich nicht darin erschöpfen sonne dem
wähler nach dem mund zu reden vor allem
dem eigenen wähler das also politiker
über die eigene parteibasis hinaus
decken sollten also die aufregung
interessanterweise macht sich einem
leicht veränderten zitat ja fest also
diejenigen die das dann
als besonders skandal würde ich ja in
umlauf bringen sagen tut immer so als ob
frau bär wird gesagt habe ist ihr seien
die deutschen wähler egal wer hat das
gesagt ihr sein ihre wähler egal sie
spricht ausreden also aus berufung meile
wähler
und das finde ich noch erstmal sich so
gelöst werden und grünen politiker sagt
dass eben die grün ist nicht die erste
stelle steht oder das ist jetzt mit viel
ironie und trotzdem deutet diese aussage
auf ein problem hin dass gerade auch die
bundesregierung hat und wahrscheinlich
zunehmend haben wird richtung herbst
richtung winter dass nämlich der druck
zunimmt dass wir alle unsere gas und
stromrechnungen bezahlen müssen die ja
maximal teuer geworden sind und
gleichzeitig wird die regierung eben
weiter das erklären müssen warum man
gleichzeitig eben unbedingt solidarität
üben möchte mit der ukraine das sehen
viele deutsche in dem widerspruch und
darauf deutet ja diese aussage hin der
flasche oder
ja an der krieg in der ukraine also
überfall auf die ukraine kostet und was
sehen wir also die ersten haben ja schon
die neuen stromrechnungen bekommen oder
die ersten
ankündigung was demnächst das gas kosten
wird und deswegen überlegt die
bundesregierung ja auch wie sie
denjenigen die damit überfordert sind
helfen kann so aber
für ich sage also würde ich doch man
sagt erstmal
recht moskau richten und nicht auf an
die grünen bundeskanzlerin was ist jetzt
ehrlich gesagt die forderung dass wir
unseren präparat frieden mit moskau
schließen es sind ja interessanterweise
auch innen deswegen leute vor allem
empört jetzt bei einer entweder der afg
oder der linkspartei
leben finden dass wir uns da raus halten
sollten und allem blitzen wir nutzten in
der tat ob man in der tat der brauch
zeit gute argumente nur das problem ist
wenn wir irgendwann eine mehrheit haben
gegen die sanktionen und trotzdem muss
die regierung ihre politik erklären in
diesem dilemma steckt die regierung zu
nehmen und steckt die bundes
außenministerin zunehmend diese gerade
schon zur bundeskanzlerin gemacht haben
herr fleischhauer so geht es nicht die
grüne bundeskanzlerin die grüne
bundesaußenministerium also was sie wie
wie kann sie reagieren wenn ihr
sozusagen die mehrheit abhanden kommt
unter den deutschen
ja also noch ist die mehrheit nicht
verloren die umfang die ich gesehen habe
ist jetzt noch nicht so dass die
mehrheit der deutschen dafür ist
dass wir uns irgendwie mit dem aggressor
ins benehmen setzen sondern die mehrheit
ist nach wie vor der meinung das ist
richtig ist dass sie die ukraine
unterstützen und ich erinnere doch
nochmal jetzt vielleicht an helmut
schmidt der als bundeskanzler anders als
frau wird gesehen
etwas voraus geeilt
alle haben ihn wahnsinnig gelobt dafür
dass er damals denn nach doppel
beschluss durchgesetzt hat und zwar
gegen seine eigene partei und auch große
teile im linken spektrum und das werden
alle wahnsinnig
ehrenhaft ja in diesem fall sich über
den weder willen im eigenen lager hinweg
zu setzen so
und daran gemessen für mich gemacht
vellberg nicht das falsche das hat ja so
viele empört und viele haben gestern
sofort an den amtseid von annalena
baerbock erinnert haben wir schon
gezeigt können wir gerade noch mal kurz
rein horchen an den höhepunkt ihrer
karriere also an denen von annalena
baerbock als sie eben vereidigt wurde
von bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas im
bundestag de rijk lautet ich schwöre
dass ich meine kraft dem wohle des
deutschen volkes widmen seinen nutzen
mehren schaden von ihm wenden das
grundgesetz und die gesetze des bundes
wahren und verteidigen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde
ich schwöre es herzlichen glückwunsch
und alles
[Applaus]
die entscheidende frage jetzt herr
fleischhauer verstößt sie gegen den 1
wenn sie jetzt in prag sagt wir sind die
eigenen wähler wurscht
ganz im gegenteil
also wir wollen die unterstützung der
ukraine machen wir doch nicht unter
deutschen volk zu quälen und die
unterstützung der ukraine machen wir
weil wir davon ausgehen wenn herr putin
das schafft sich die ukraine zu krallen
dass du damit nicht schluss macht das
hat ja auch angekündigt da sind dann
nächstes und als nächstes sind die
beiden staaten dran ja und dann weiß man
gar nicht wo er aufhören will ich mein
erklärtes ziel der
russlands die die grenzen die neue im
nach der wiedervereinigung gezogen
worden oder im einheitsprozess
aufzulösen also das alte vor 1989 europa
wiederherzustellen so und ich glaube das
ist es ja auch die argumentation der
bundesregierung dass der preis den wir
dann zahlen wenn wir die unterstützung
der ukraine einstellen sehr viel höher
ist als ein kalter winter und insofern
ein auto meiner sicht wird frau beer
wird in diesem fall ihren amtseid
gerecht aber jetzt doch noch monate
vorsieht das gilt jetzt für diesen fall
also es ist nicht der pauschal scheck
für alles weitere was in den nächsten
sechs monaten folgt schon das tut mir
ein bisschen weh die grüne
außenministerin zu haben in diesem fall
aber trotzdem ganz klar hinter dieser
aussage die für ihren fleischauer
eindeutig haltung beweist danke ihnen
heute früh
[Musik]